the term bright I don't much care for
but hey we did the best we could with it
I was with Richard Dawkins in Clearwater
Florida
and I had a few other people who
brainstorm that came up with the idea of
having the brights I think I was maybe
the third or fourth person to to sign
the the membership roster and a bright
is someone who thinks logically and
rationally phases his or her decisions
upon rationality and Ponta logic and
upon evidence that's the major thing
right there and if we don't have
evidence we can express our our belief
or lack of belief in it but it has to be
provisional I believe that this is
probably true though I don't have any
evidence for or against it is a
perfectly safe statement and so brights
base all of their decisions and their
beliefs on logic rationality and on
evidence that's the thing that different
they in which they differ from the
average person who takes anything that
comes along that looks attracted oh I
like that
I think I'll believe in it
not that I know I am an atheist tried
and true I have been since I was oh I
guess about this tall I'm only about
this tall now and I made up made that
made up my mind that I was going to
investigate all these things and
question them I went to Sunday school I
was tossed I just went to school
immediately but it gave me 25 cents that
I could have put in the contribution
plate there's he when they passed the
plate around and I found other at
prettiest drugstore you could buy a to
flavor ice cream sundae for 25 cents and
that was a great discovery in my
childhood I must say and I took full
advantage of it my parents bless him
never found out and I went off every
Sunday morning as if going to Sunday
school but I lied and I'm ashamed to
admit it now and if my my dad mom were
up there someplace or down there
someplace I have no idea I asked him to
forgive me